GOVERNOR AND SECRETARY OF STATE
COULD AFFECT TURNOUT.
STEVE: LET’S BRING IN KAYLEIGIGH
McENANY.
SHE IS THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY ON THE NORTH LAWN.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD TO JOIN YOU.
STEVE: OKAY.
GRIFF WAS JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
SITUATION DOWN IN GEORGIA WHERE
THEY HAVE THE TWIN RUN-OFF RACES
FIRST WEEK IN JANUARY.
AND HE BROUGHT UP, YOU KNOW, THE
PRESIDENT IS TALKING ABOUT HOW
THE ELECTION WAS RIGGED AND
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE WORRIED THAT
THAT KIND OF THINGS COULD
BACKFIRE ON THAT PARTICULAR RUN
OFF ELECTION BECAUSE THEY SAY,
YOU KNOW, IF IT’S RIG YOU HAD,
IF THE 2020 NOVEMBER ELECTION
WAS RIGGED, AND THIS ONE IS
RIGGED, WHY SHOULD I EVEN BOTHER
VOTING?
>> YOU KNOW, LEAVE IT TO THE
CAMPAIGN TO PONTIFICATE ON THE
PRESIDENT’S STRATEGY.
STEVE: SOMETIMES YOU ARE WITH
THE CAMPAIGN SO YOU KNOW THE
THINKING THERE.
>> I DO.
I’M JOINING YOU IN MY OFFICIAL
CAPACITY TODAY FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE LAWN BUT I WILL SAY, THIS
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
UNAPOLOGETIC FOR THE LAST 10
MONTHS IN SAYING THAT MAIL IN
VOTING.
MASS MAIL-IN VOTING IS SUBJECT
TO FRAUD.
THIS HAS BEEN A KEY PART OF WHAT
HE HAS TALKED ABOUT WHEN IT
COMES TO ELECTION INTEGRITY.
HE WANTS TO MAKE SURE SIGNATURES
ARE MATCHED.
STEVE: RIGHT.
>> THE MAIL-IN VOTING IS SACCO
SANK AND TWEETED WITH THE
INTEGRITY THAT EVERY AMERICAN
VOTER DESERVES.
STEVE: CAN’T THAT COME BACK TO
BACKFIRE WITH THIS GEORGIA
SPECIAL ELECTION?
>> NO.
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT, AGAIN,
LOOK, IF YOU GO BACK TO WHEN
NANCY PELOSI TOOK THE GAVEL, THE
VERY FIRST BILL SHE PUT IN PLACE
WAS HR-1.
THIS WAS ALLOWING PEOPLE ON
VOTING ROLLS, ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ON VOTING ROLLS, NO SIGNATURE
MATCHING.
DEMOCRATS FOR YEARS, FAR BEFORE
THE 2016 ELECTION, THE 2020
ELECTION, RATHER, HAVE TRIED TO
MAKE OUR ELECTION SYSTEM LESS
SECURE.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR THAT WHILE
ALSO SAYING IT’S IMPORTANT TO
TURN OUT AND VOTE WHILE ALSO
PERFECTING THE SYSTEM.
AINSLEY: KELLY, RESPOND TO THIS,
THEY PUT OUT AN ARTICLE ABOUT
THE FEMALE STAFF.
COMMUNICATION STAFF THAT BIDEN
HAS SELECTED.
THEY WROTE FOUR OF THE SEVEN TOP
COMMUNICATION ROLES AT THE WHITE
HOUSE WILL BE FILLED BY WOMEN OF
COLOR AND IT’S THE FIRST TIME
THE ENTIRE SENIOR WHITE HOUSE
COMMUNICATIONS TEAM WILL BE
ENTIRELY FEMALE.
I KNOW THAT YOU BLASTED THE
PAPER.
SOME OF YOUR STAFFERS DID SAY
HEY, LOOK AT US WE ARE ALL
FEMALE.
THEN YOU HAD A GUY WHO IS ONE OF
THE STAFFERS WHO WORKS ON YOUR
TEAM.
I KNOW ALL THE BOSSES ARE
FEMALES.
SINGS I ARRIVED AT THE TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE A WOMAN HAS ALWAYS
BEEN MY BOSS, FIRST HOPE HIX,
MERCEDES SCHLAPP AND SARAH
HUCKABEE SANDERS AND GRISHAM AND
KAYLEIGH McENANY AND ELISE.
I GUESS THE MEDIA FORGOT.
HIS NAME IS JUDD DEERE.
WHAT’S YOUR REACTION BECAUSE
THEY ARE SAYING YOU ARE LYING
ABOUT IT?
>> JUDD DEERE IS A GRATE MEMBER
OF OUR TEAM.
EVERY SENIOR ROLE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE IS A FEMALE.
THIS PRESIDENT, OUT OF THE FIVE
PRESS SECRETARIES THAT HAVE BEEN
WOMEN, THREE OF THEM HAVE BEEN
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE APPOINTED THE FIRST WORKING
MOM IN SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS
AND APPOINTED ANOTHER WORKING
MOM AND ME WITH A NEWBORN UNDER
THE AGE OF 1.
CONSISTENTLY EMPOWERED WOMEN.
THE DOUBLE STANDARD IN THE MEDIA
IS ABSOLUTELY ABSURD.
IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT WOMAN WHO
COMES INTO THE WEST WING BEHIND
ME WHO TAKES THAT PODIUM, YOUR
BIGGEST CONCERN OUTSIDE OF YOUR
OFFICIAL DUTIES IS THE NEXT
GLOWING PROFILE WRITTEN ABOUT
YOU.
IF YOU ARE A TOO MAIL WOMAN IN
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY WHO TAKES
THAT PODIUM, GUESS WHAT YOUR
WORRY IS?
HAVING A PLAYBOY REPORTER SHOUT
QUESTIONS AT YOU, DEMEANING
MISOGYNISTIC QUESTIONS DURING A
BRIEFING.
IT’S A DOUBLE STANDARD.
ONE THAT’S RIDICULOUS AND ONE
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT’S ASSOCIATION
SHOULD LOOK INTO WHEN YOU HAVE
PLAYBOY REPORTERS SHOUTING AT
WOMEN IN IS I MISOGYNY
CHAUVINISTIC SIMPLY BECAUSE YOU
ARE A MEMBER OF THE G.O.P.
BRIAN: OPERATION WARP SPEED WE
ARE WAITING THE PLANES ARE READY
TO GO AND THE VACCINE IS READY
TO GO.
THE FDA ISN’T YET.
ACCORDING TO AXIOS MARK MEADOWS
HAS NOT TO A ZOOM CALL AND SHOW
UP IN PERSON AND EXPLAIN WHAT
THE DELAY IS THERE IS A SENSE
THEY ARE NOT WORKING AROUND THE
CLOCK AND THAT HE WENT TO THE
OUTER BANKS TO QUARANTINE OR
VACATION WHEN YOU SHOULD BE PUSH
BEING THE MODERNA VACCINE BEFORE
THE MIDDLE OF DECEMBER AND
PFIZER VACCINE AS OF YESTERDAY.
I KNOW IT’S EASY TO PUNT ON
THIS, BUT WHAT COULD YOU TELL
US?
IS THERE A LITTLE BIT OF TENSION
THAT MAYBE THE FDA IS NOT
WORKING AS HARD AS THE CDC AND
OTHERS LIKE YOURSELF AND THE
PRESIDENT?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I DON’T WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THE MEETINGS THAT
WILL BE GOING ON TODAY IN THE
WEST WINGS BUT WHAT I WILL SAY
IS, THIS WE ARE WORKING AROUND
THE CLOCK.
YOU HAD MONC EF ABSOLUTELY SAY A
VACCINE JUDICIALLY TAKES FOUR
YEARS AND 25 YEARS.
BRIAN: IS THERE A SENSE THAT THE
FDA ISN’T?
>> THE FDA IS WORKING AROUND THE
CLOCK HERE THIS IS A PARTNERSHIP
OF EVERYONE WANTS TO SEE
AMERICAN LIVES SAVED FROM
DR. STEPHEN HUN TO THIS
PRESIDENT.
THIS PRESIDENT WILL NEVER
APOLOGIZE FOR PUTTING THE FIRE
UNDER THESE AGENCIES TO SAY YES
WE WANT A SAFE VACCINE,
ABSOLUTELY.
WE ALSO WANT A FAST ONE BECAUSE
LIVES ARE AT STAKE.
VACCINE BY THE END OF THE YEAR
CAN KEY AND PARAMOUNT AND
EXACTLY WHAT THIS PRESIDENT HAS
DONE TO BE RAPID BUT SAFE.
STEVE: RIGHT.
IN THE EARLY DAYS THE
ADMINISTRATION SAID TO THE
GOVERNORS YOU KNOW WHAT BECAUSE
DIFFERENT LOCALITIES HAVE
DIFFERENT CONDITIONS, EVERYBODY
SHOULD BE IN CHARGE OF THINGS IN
THEIR OWN STATE.
SOME OF THE GOVERNORS ARE
TALKING ABOUT MORE LOCKDOWNS OR
RESTRICTIONS, I KNOW IN RHODE
ISLAND YESTERDAY THEY SENT OUT A
TEXT ALERT TO EVERYBODY HEY FOR
THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS TRY TO
STAY AS CLOSE TO HOME AS YOU
POSSIBLY CAN HOW DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION FEEL ABOUT THESE
NEW RESTRICTIONS IN VARIOUS
PLACES ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE IT LOOKS AS IF RIGHT
NOW, YOU KNOW, THERE IS
SOMETHING LIKE 41 STATES THAT IT
IS SPIKING IN.
>> YEAH.
WE’RE AT A DIFFERENT PLACE
TODAY.
LOOK, WE LOCKED DOWN THE COUNTRY
ONCE.
IT’S BECAUSE THERE IT WAS A
NOVEL VIRUS THAT CAME IN THAT WE
DID NOT HAVE THERAPEUTICS FOR.
THAT WE DID NOT KNOW HOW TO
HANDLE BECAUSE WE DIDN’T HAVE
TESTING IT WAS NOVEL.
NO ONE HAD EVER SEEN COVID-19.
WE KNOW HOW TO HANDLE IT NOW.
AMERICANS, WE ARE RESPONSIBLE.
WE KNOW HOW TO WASH OUR HANDS
AND SOCIALLY DISTANCE AND WEAR A
MASK AND MAKE WISE DECISIONS.
BUT GOVERNORS SHOULD TRUST THEIR
PEOPLE TO MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISIONS.
THIS PRESIDENT IS ABOUT FREEDOM.
IS HE NOT ABOUT SHUTTING DOWN
BUSINESSES.
HE IS NOT ABOUT LOCKING DOWN
STATES.
AND HE IS CERTAINLY NOT ABOUT
LOCKING DOWN PLACES OF RELIGIOUS
WORSHIP WHICH THE SUPREME COURT
SAID IT WAS UNCONSTITUTIONAL
WHAT GOVERNOR CUOMO WAS DOING
THERE IN NEW YORK BECAUSE, YES,
WE HAVE A PANDEMIC.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE A UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION AND THOSE FREEDOMS
MATTER EVEN AMID A PANDEMIC.
AINSLEY: KAYLEIGH I’M READING AN
ARTICLE REPORT OKAY JOE MANCHIN
INTERVIEWING HIM HE THINKS
1.2 TRILLION IS ACCEPTABLE WHICH
IS HALF OF HIS MODERATE AND
WANTS TO WORK WITH REPUBLICANS.
A WOMAN WHO OWNED A RESTAURANTS
WITH EVERYWHERE EARLIER IN OUR
SHOW SHE NEEDS TO LAY OFF
EMPLOYEES CAN’T DO IT CLOSE TO
CHRISTMAS.
A PREGNANT WOMAN WAS IN HER
OFFICE CRYING PLEASE DON’T LAY
ME OFF.
THEY ARE NOT MAKING MONEY
BECAUSE SHE OWNS A RESTAURANT.
PEOPLE NEED HELP, WHAT’S THE
LATEST.
>> JOE MANCHIN NEEDS TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION WITH NANCY PELOSI WHO
HAS BEEN FUNDAMENTALLY UNSERIOUS
IN A WAY THAT’S IRRESPONSIBLE
AND QUITE FRANKLY GUSSING THAT
SHE RESUMES THE HOUSE, PUTS THE
HOUSE BACK IN SESSION AND WHAT
ARE THE BILLS SHE PUTS FORWARD?
ABOUT LEGALIZING MARIJUANA.
ABOUT GOING AFTER TIGER KING AND
REGULATING THE USE OF TIGERS.
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE RELIEF
THAT’S NEEDED.
HER STIMULUS BILL WAS CHOCK-FULL
OF, GUESS WHAT MAIL-IN VOTING
REGULATIONS TO TRY TO SECURE
DEMOCRAT POWER IN THE HALLS OF
CONGRESS WHILE THIS PRESIDENT
SAID NANCY PELOSI YOU WON’T
NEGOTIATE WITH ME?
GUESS WHAT I WILL DO PROTECTIONS
FROM EVICTION.
I WILL DO MORE FUNDING FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE VIA
EXECUTIVE ORDER.
HE HAS BEEN SERIOUS WHILE NANCY
PELOSI HAS BEEN DERELICT IN HER
DUTIES.
SHE DOES NOT DESERVE TO BE
SPEAKER EVER AGAIN.
BRIAN: SHE ALMOST LOST IT THIS
TIME THEY WERE WITHIN STRIKING
DISTANCE.
MITCH McCONNELL IS PUTTING THE
HEAT UP ON NANCY PELOSI.
THERE IS NO REASON FOR THEM NOT
TO HAVE THEIR RELIEF PACKAGE AND
JOE MANCHIN, SENATOR WARNER AND
DICK DURBIN ARE WORKING WITH
MURKOWSKI, ROM ANYTHING, CASSIDY
AND COLLINS TO TRY TO GET
SOMETHING DONE.
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET FROM
BOTTOM UP LEADERSHIP TO ACTUALLY
ACT.
WILL THE PRESIDENT PICK UP THE
PHONE AND GET THEM TO ACT?
WILL HE PUT THE PRESSURE ON LIKE
HE ALWAYS DOES BEHIND THE
PODIUM?
>> HE HAS CONTINUALLY PUT THE
PRESSURE ON.
I CAN TELL YOU HAVING HAD DAILY
DISCUSSIONS WITH CHIEF OF STAFF
MARK MEADOWS, THE SECRETARY OF
THE TREASURY, STEVE MNUCHIN,
THEY HAVE CONSISTENTLY MOVED
TOWARDS NANCY PELOSI ON BEHALF
OF THE PRESIDENT AS HIS
SURROGATE GOING TOWARDS THE
HILL.
NANCY PELOSI HAS BEEN
LAUGHABLABLE.
SHE WANTS THIS AMOUNT OF FUNDING
TO OPEN SCHOOLS AND WE GIVE THAT
WE GIVE MORE THAN THAT AND SHE
REJECTS IT.
SHE HAS BEEN UNSERIOUS.
SO WE’LL CONTINUE TO MOVE TOWARD
THE LEFT BUT THAT BIPARTISAN
GROUP AGAIN NEEDS TO PUT
PRESSURE ON THE RADICALS AOCs
OF THE WORLD AND ILHAN OMARS
THAT CONTROL NANCY PELOSI LIKE A
MARION NETTED PUNTD.
AINSLEY: I THOUGHT IT WAS KIND
OF THE PRESIDENT TO REACH OUT TO
JOE BIDEN ON TWITTER AND SAY
LOOK I WISH YOU THE BEST AND
HOPE YOU GET WELL SON.
SOON.
SOME WERE QUESTIONING WHETHER HE
WAS SINCERE.
WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION?
WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT’S
REACTION.
>> THE PRESIDENT WAS BEING
SINCERE.
WE ARE ONE COUNTRY.
WE ALL HAVE OUR PARTIES.
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE ARE
ALL-AMERICAN.
THAT’S WHAT THIS PRESIDENT
UNDERSTANDS.
LEAVE IT TO THE MEDIA TO
CONTINUALLY TAKE HIM OUT OF
CONTEXT.
THINK THE WORSE OF HIM.
IT’S JUST WHAT THEY DO AND WE
ARE USED TO THAT HERE IN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT, KAYLEIGH,
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US ON THE